♪♪
-Let's get to the news!
While speaking to reporters
last week
about the ongoing investigation
into classified documents
found at his home,
President Biden defended
his handling of the files
that had been discovered and
said he has "no regrets."
Well, technically,
he didn't say it.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden's attorney
announced on Saturday
that FBI agents found six more
classified documents
during a search
of his Delaware home.
Oh, my God, how long
is this gonna go on?
I don't have that many
un-classified documents
in my house.
And how big is Biden's house?
Every day, there's a new update,
like, "Oops,
just found some
in the guest library."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you know they're onto you.
Why wouldn't you get everything
all gathered up?
When you were in college, and
the cops knocked on your door,
did you just flush
some of the weed?
[ Laughter ]
I don't get it.
Do all politicians do this?
Is that why Jimmy Carter
is still building houses?
[ Laughter ]
Just to store
all his classified documents?
[ Laughter ]
I think they're worried
I'm gonna do my Carter.
[ Laughter ]
Former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo's new memoir
is set to be released this week,
and just to save time,
the title of the book
is "80 Percent Off."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, don't look
in these new houses."
[ Laughter ]
The Senate was set to reconvene
this afternoon at 3:00
after a 20-day break because
nothing says
"Let's get down to business"
like starting work
at 3:00 on a Monday.
[ Laughter ]
Three men in California
were recently arrested
for attempting to rob
a cannabis dispensary
after they led police
on a high-speed chase
and crashed into a solar panel.
Man, that sounds
like you asked your grandpa
to make up a news story
about California.
[ Laughter ]
A horse in Australia
was recently spotted
in the back seat of a car
entering a McDonald's
drive-through,
but not leaving.
[ Laughter ]
So I can't tell.
Yea on that joke or neigh?
[ Laughter ]
Pretty good restraint.
Mike Scollins wrote that joke,
and we were very worried
that the burger was gonna have,
like, a mane.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Rhode Island
recently agreed
to a child's request
to DNA-test
leftover Christmas cookies
for evidence of Santa Claus.
And they're not gonna like
what they found out.
Uh-oh, looks like Santa
murdered a guy in '96.
[ Laughter ]
Public health officials
in Massachusetts
have discovered
a new strain of gonorrhea
that is resistant
to most antibiotics.
Massachusetts, where even the
gonorrhea likes to fight stuff.
[ Laughter ]
"You think you're better
than me, penicillin?"
[ Laughter ]
Finally, according to
the latest numbers,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
has made $2 billion
at the global box office,
which is incredible.
Only $1 billion more
for the movie to break even.
[ Laughter ]
CNN has reported that a lawyer
for former vice president
Mike Pence
found a dozen
classified documents last week
at Pence's Indiana home.
Okay, so they're just
in every home?
That's the only thing
that makes sense anymore.
When you buy a new house
and you move in,
there's just classified
documents sitting on the counter
next to that half roll of paper
towels and box of baking soda.
President Biden is expected to
spend the weekend at Camp David,
and you know
it's been a rough week
when you start making
your weekend plans on Tuesday.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department
is reportedly considering plans
to search other locations
connected to President Biden
as part of its investigation
into his handling
of classified documents,
which could include everywhere
from Cold Stone to TCBY.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
nearly 60% of New York voters
think Republican congressman
George Santos should resign,
while according to him,
180% say he shouldn't.
[ Laughter ]
That's his poll.
That's his internal polling.
A newly surfaced video
appears to show New York
congressman George Santos
saying that he survived
an assassination attempt.
I guess we can't be surprised.
There's always someone
gunning for you
when you're the star
of the volleyball team
at Baruch College.
[ Laughter ]
Former FBI official
Charles McGonigal
was arrested over the weekend
on charges of money laundering
and violating sanctions
against Russia
while working with
a Russian oligarch.
But remember, under our system,
McGonigal is innocent
until Trump calls him
a good man.
[ Laughter ]
A South Carolina woman
recently used winnings
from a scratch-off
lottery ticket
to purchase a Powerball ticket
and won $150,000
in what financial experts
are calling
still a smarter investment
strategy than crypto.
[ Laughter ]
Candy company Mars
announced yesterday
it will replace its
so-called M&M's spokescandies
in upcoming ads.
Luckily, the green one's
got another gig lined up.
[ Laughter ]
"You melted
in my husband's hands."
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Spain recently
raided a tobacco factory
accused of exploiting workers
and seized $41 million worth
of leaves and cigarettes.
And to teach them a lesson,
they're going to make them
smoke every last one of them.
[ Laughter ]
I should make whoever wrote that
smoke the joke.
[ Laughter ]
Roll it up.
And finally --
Oh, it's Scollins.
Thank you. Wally went back
to let me know who wrote it.
He wanted to make sure
I could shame him by name.
[ Laughter ]
Mike Scollins.
If you're watching,
which you probably aren't,
go smoke your joke.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, after
Disney World's Splash Mountain
officially closed yesterday,
containers of water from
the ride are being sold on eBay,
including one listing
for a four-ounce bottle for $4,
which is still way cheaper than
buying a water at Disney World.
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President
Mike Pence's lawyer
reportedly found close to
a dozen classified documents
last week at Pence's
Indiana home.
And when Pence heard that,
he stayed white as a ghost.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Mike Pence's
lawyer reportedly found close
to a dozen classified documents
last week
at Pence's Indiana home.
Man, this is starting to feel
like the beginning
of the pandemic.
You hear about one case,
then another.
And before you know it, we're
all going to be locked in
our apartments, wiping down
our mail, terrified that
some classified documents
are going to get in.
The Justice Department has now
launched an investigation into
the dozen classified documents
found at former Vice President
Mike Pence's Indiana home,
and more specifically,
why was Joe Biden
keeping them there?
[ Laughter ]
"I like to spread it out."
The Senate Judiciary Committee
held a hearing yesterday
in the Ticket Master's recent
mishandling of Taylor Swift
concert tickets,
and let's just say
we're kind of glad
we weren't there.
-I'm the problem.
It's me.
-She's cheer captain,
and I'm on the bleachers.
-We know all too well.
-Oh.
It's like when your mom tries
to impress your friends.
"Your father cheated on me,
but I'm just going
to shake it off, right, kids?"
House speaker Kevin McCarthy
told reporters yesterday
that if the Ethics Committee
finds that New York Congressman
George Santos broke the law
"then we will remove him."
So I guess it's up
to the chairman
of the Ethics Committee.
Oh, no, it's George Santos!
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Pope Francis said
he doesn't mind criticism,
and said it "helps you grow
and improve things,"
because nothing says you're
open to change like
still speaking Latin.
[ Laughter ]
The FDA yesterday proposed new
guidelines that would limit
lead levels in processed
baby food.
A real surprise to parents,
who thought
the current limit was any.
[ Laughter ]
Hm, hardly any lead.
Netflix said yesterday it plans
to start cracking down
on password sharing in March,
which only gives you
a couple months to find
something
on Netflix worth watching.
You guys want to try
"Sad Norwegian Detective"?
Apparently there's
eight seasons.
He keeps getting sadder.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of the beer
Natural Light have announced
a new logo and can.
Incidentally, natural light
is what their customers
fear most.
Ahh!
Shut the door!
And finally, a Canadian artist
recently earned
a Guinness world record
for largest spice painting
after she used turmeric,
paprika and clove
to paint a 900 square foot
butterfly.
It was supposed to 1,200 square
feet, but then she sneezed.
[ Laughter ]
It's a very, very dumb joke.
According to a new report,
the Justice Department
was prepared to obtain a warrant
if President Biden did not agree
to last week's search
of his Delaware home.
Oh, he's not the kind of guy
who won't let you in.
He's the kind of guy
who won't let you leave.
"Come on, guys."
[ Laughter ]
"One more Michelob.
I'm gonna get out my guitar."
New York Mayor Eric Adams told
reporters yesterday
he does not believe asylum
seekers
should qualify
for the same protections
that require the city to provide
shelter to homeless people.
In related news,
the Statue of Liberty
walked into the Hudson River.
[ Laughter ]
New York Congressman
George Santos
gave his first floor speech
yesterday
and quoted former President
Ronald Reagan,
or as Santos calls him, "Dad."
[ Laughter ]
"My living dad."
Former President Trump has
reportedly begun texting.
This news first reported
by Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ] Throwback.
Trump has already reportedly
stopped picking up calls
from numbers
that are not in his contacts,
which is surprising
since you'd think he'd jump
at the chance to pick up
a call that says "scam likely."
[ Laughter ]
"I think you and I are going to
have a lot in common..."
[ Laughter ]
"...Scam Likely."
[ Chuckles ]
Transportat--
That was
his Secret Service name.
[ Laughter ]
The Transportation Department
has announced
that it is in the early stages
of its investigation
into Southwest Airlines'
handling of flight cancelations
during last month's
holiday season...
and should be done by the time
everyone makes it home.
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests
that Earth's inner core
may have stopped turning
and could go in reverse.
Shouldn't have
gotten the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
A passenger on an Emirates
flight to Dubai
recently gave birth midflight.
Not to be outdone, a passenger
on Spirit...got pregnant!
[ Laughter, applause ]
I just used a technique called
Amy Poehler-ing the punch line.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities
in Connecticut
are looking for a thief
who recently stole
two designer bags
and a hairless cat,
or as the thief believed,
three designer bags.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh [no audio]"
[ Hissing ]
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.